hello there welcome to another
commentary video so in this commentary
video we're going to do
a quick breakdown of a deleted scene
where general grievous
kills shark tea so yeah let's get
straight into the video
shakti so this deleted scene would be
towards the star of the film anakin and
obi-wan
are still under invisible handship and
they have just walked into what seems
like a chap with shark t
taken captive with general grievous i'm
sorry master kenobi
i failed so right here in this clip
general grievous is playing with um
shark t's head piece
and what i really love about this scene
right here is that it shows
a more menacing side to grievous the
more creepy side to them
makes them more of like a person to be
feared and
he really adds another layer to his
character and how he doesn't really
care about other people and how he's
using them it also shows that you know
he shows no mercy because as we see in a
second he'll just
kill sharks here with no negotiation so
the negotiations were short
and you know that really shows what
general grievous's character is he's a
jedi assassin
general kenobi we've been waiting for
you
stinking [ __ ]
that was a bad mistake
no no no no this is not a good time to
argue master
might i recommend
far too many of them flat so what i love
here is that
anakin and obi-wan's relationship is
more encapsulated in this scene you can
see the more like brotherly hood that
they have
and the banter that they share together
i really do like the scene but i can see
where they took it out because um
it really does slow down the pacing of
the movie and it kind of is redundant
it doesn't add too much to the story
although it does you know
build upon the character development of
anakin obi-wan and
uh more so general grievous i think it
really adds to grievous character here
you know really shows him as the jedi
hunter that he is
so i love how anakin and obi-wan kind of
have like their
own um sign language where they're
communicating with
with movements and stuff i think that's
i think that's great
as i said before it really shows their
relationship
um and how at one stage it was a really
good relationship um into a sadly broken
part
in the later rents of episode three but
in this clip here we really see that
brotherly hood
as i spoke about before so yeah let's
continue
[Music]
obviously the cgi um is not complete in
the scene because it is a deleted scene
so if you're wondering why the scene
doesn't look very good um with the water
and stuff you know that's because it's
not finished
well we're safe for the time being your
idea of safe is not the same as mine
and then yep we just got another quick
clip of anakin and everyone's banter
which you know we could always use more
of that come on
i'm one of those people where i loved
hayden christensen as
a mannequin and of course love erwin
mcgregor as
obi-wan kenobi i think they had great
chemistry together i think
they're both fantastic actors and i hope
to see i'm hayden christensen
back as anakin which i think he may be
back into obi-wan kenobi series which
i'm really really excited for
um but yeah anyway um let me know in the
comment section below what you think
of this deleted scene do you think it
should have stayed in the movie or do
you think it was a good decision to cut
it out
and also what do you think of this
format of videos do you guys want to see
more deleted scene breakdowns or do you
have any other video suggestions
please let me know in the comment
section below with that out of the way
i'll catch you guys
in the next video